in 2018 more than 108,000 people
finished ultramarathons in the US alone
an ultramarathon is any race longer than
42 kilometers and races can range
anywhere from 50 to over 4000 kilometers
but one of the more common lengths
covers about 100 kilometers and takes on
average 17 hours to finish in some of
the longer races half the runners never
see the finish line and that's because
these races not only push you to your
mental limit they take a toll on your
body both inside and out ultra runners
endure some pretty extreme conditions
the Badwater ultramarathon for example
covers 4000 meters of elevation through
Death Valley in July one of the hottest
months of the year temperatures can
reach up to 47 degrees Celsius causing
headaches and dizziness and many runners
but even if you're running in more
comfortable weather you could still be
feeling sick to your stomach one of the
most common issues in any ultra marathon
is nausea or vomiting it affects about
37 percent of people who complete a race
but it's also the number one reason
runners won't finish in the first place
that's because running disrupts your
digestion it diverts blood away from
your stomach to your muscles and since
ultra marathons lasts so long many races
provide sandwiches pasta and other carb
loaded meals but as a result that food
will just sit around undigested causing
a lot of problems but if your stomach
isn't slowing you down your eyes could
be causing you grief windy conditions
can dry out or damage the cells that
pump a protective liquid layer over your
cornea which can cause it to swell up
and blur your vision during the hellgate
100k for example runners report losing
most of their vision by the end of the
race they call it hellgate eyes but no
amount of protection or preparation can
prevent one
symptom that's sleepiness for a 17-hour
race it might not be so bad but longer
races can stretch for more than 24 hours
which can make sleepy runners more prone
to trips and Falls or worse
hallucinations the Berkeley marathons
for example is a race where runners are
given 60 hours to finish a 161
kilometers in 2005 one runner reported
that he thought he saw houses at the top
of the mountain and believed he was
their garbage man sent to pick up their
trash despite these health hazards ultra
running is a growing sport believe it or
not one study found that compared to
marathoners ultra runners are more
likely to do it for nature and a sense
of purpose than for the competitive
aspect so if you're up for the challenge
plenty of races are on trails through
natural areas so at least you'll get a
great view you might be hallucinating
that you're someone's garbage man but it
will look pretty
[Music]